but my piece was throbbing you know I
mean it was about sex four times in a
row bro and yeah like a heart and I was
done there a snake you're just staring
at nah nah I broke it so what nine times
out of ten if you tweet us I'm probably
gonna get back to you me personally
because I love to do I mean it's a good
way to engage with the fans engage with
the people not just fine just anyone
really I love it and it's funny
we're funny guys fill me
do you remember random hmm do you
remember the first time you introduced
me to Childish Gambino yes I think I do
what's your what what do you think it
was recollection the recollection for me
is we were worried and worried in the
library or something yeah in the down in
the base in the basement thing yeah I
don't remember how I what I showed you
but I remember I'm a bit so what
happened was we went that down says boy
in the library this is back in Coventry
so this was probably borderline 1011
years ago and this guy was watching a
YouTube video called freaks and geeks my
charge can be no and then he asked me if
I'd seen or I'd heard it I was like nah
but um and I watched outside oh my days
this guy's [ __ ] sick like yeah that
was a that was the first introduction I
ever had of charge Gambino
a K dollar Glover and I was like no this
guy is hard and obviously that was at
that point that was his biggest song
because that was the one that got most
you know most was the word I'm looking
for publicity an attraction attraction
yeah and then I started to do my
research and I start listening to all
his and all the stuff back then so he
had like a few mixtapes like I am was a
chord like I am a DJ DJ part apartment
what it called like but this guy the
reason why just ask because this guy is
such a [ __ ] work ethic it's
unbelievable so obviously I've known
charge gonna be know somewhat since my
first year of uni which was 10 year 11
years ago when I followed his journey up
until now
and you just released a new album like
we can offer go two weeks ago if that
entire come over the album's called but
yeah ten years ago freaks it slide off a
freaks and geeks and honestly I said
listen to all these random mixtapes back
in then and I'm thinking that I like did
a bit of research and just like googling
because I was interested in mean in his
in his craft realized he was a DJ before
didn't know he did stand-up comedy
whatsoever like whatsoever when I just
kept a list ease me excited histories
mixtapes and then listen to the
cul-de-sac mixtape which was the one
that had the the Adele sample oh that
was that was one of the greatest things
I've heard and I'll find out what the
song's called and I'll put it somewhere
in the link below where von Karman book
and then yeah so listen to that listen
to that and then obviously I found out
that he was an actor as well hmm
and then I started to watch community I
think I don't know if you put me on
community it was my brother put me onto
community yeah and then I might put you
and I can't remember what you maybe you
did put me on purely because you knew I
love charge of Camino and I'm waiting
then obviously I was tired to watch it I
was figuring this guy is sick he can rap
he can DJ he can act and it still I
didn't know he did comedy up until that
point yeah boy and then I think when I
got Netflix on a point he hit a few of
these Netflix stand-ups what on down I
was like damn he's busy this guy can do
everything you know he's a writer on
community as well I didn't know that
until after community that ended yeah he
wrote for 30 rock okay yeah and then
when I was doing research or more
research on him that's when I knew he
wrote for community as well and then
obviously he left community in season 5
to pursue
well did it was it to pursue his acting
like he's he's no idea left it to do his
music career like it to go even bigger
in his music career and that's when he
released because the internet mmm and
then once that job that was I saw that
tour in London
when he came to London when I went with
Jesse and went to Brixton and he was one
of the best things I've ever witnessed
bro ever witnessed bro saw him when he
drops redbone yeah I saw him that one
yeah my love you saw him and perform
that I didn't see that one that one was
sick I know they showed me the
the recording of that and when he when
he dropped ribbon at the end yeah after
that I think he left he left the
industry for a while the music intro and
then this guy just like acting
everywhere everywhere yeah boy I was
like [ __ ] this guy's so good
he dropped awaken my love unbeknown to
anyone mmm and anyone to do Lion King
and all that and then dropped another
like 10 years and across this guy is
just man's I hear doing I giving
everything and he did what's it guava
island I forgot about that we've Rihanna
ah he's just does everything man this
guy is a busy guy man or work on it I
think he's one of the hardest work apart
from like probably the rock and probably
kept in her heart the - yeah like he is
one of the hardest-working people I've
ever I'd say no but I don't really I
don't even know but I feel like I do
know him because I feel like I've grown
with him throughout his career cuz I
follow him yeah I'm an advocate those
was a [ __ ] sick you don't you see
someone who when you're introduced to
their their their art or whatever and
you know are sick and then you just you
keep up with them and then you you
realize like [ __ ] hell this person's
made it maybe they made it in like the
space of 10 11 years and that's the same
thing we Drake I member the first time I
listen to Drake my boy Jamar hooked me
up with the what was that album cord
I can't see him head [ __ ] what's it
called was the first first first
everyone he dropped the mixtape that had
brand-new and all that showing it is
that white pyramid with a chick on the
top yeah camera I've come with what I
was called but mmm Jamal Jamal hooked me
up with that and and this was when I was
in year 12 or year 13 mm [ __ ] this guy
can spit yeah and I just followed him on
everything he did something new he was
signed to Young Money Obama Brian look
at 10 literally now he's the biggest the
biggest artists in the world like hands
down hands down right now the biggest
guy he's a booked a busy guy like I
followed this guy's journey this is how
do you activate fans accumulate fans
rather I was like damn late years years
bro bro it's crazy but it doesn't feel
like it's that don't feel like it's been
10 years yeah exactly why it doesn't
feel like it's been 10 years he just
flies by saying well yeah same with the
childish wing doesn't feel like it's
been 10 years since then but yeah in
those 10 years bang skywalk insistent
since he's done everything everything
that is work ethic month yeah imagine
where this could be the 10 years seems
long it doesn't we doing this Antonius I
hope so
girag has been doing his podcast 10
years just gone New Year's New Year's
Eve or New Year's Day this year
Oh 10 years Wow and he's he went from
just nothing was he doing his pod before
he was doing stand-up no he was doing
stunts he's been doing stand-up since
like the 90s oh wow he was doing
stand-up in like 89 1989 started I think
my sister was born then yeah and then he
just left like you had like high school
or something and then he was doing
stand-up just then and then he did
another show just like a TV show and he
did like was the cord
what's that [ __ ] thing good he was on
fear factor yeah he was the host for
fear factor okay four years back to USA
yeah yeah yeah he was doing that for
years and then he was just stand up all
the time and then he did ten years ago
he did the podcast
Wow and now the poke experiences yeah
yeah
and that's that now that's that's the
main thing he's known for now mmm people
forget ease we do stand-up for funny bro
man they are good but if you're not
everything you've never seen you stand
up on Netflix please watch them is good
so yeah if it's wild when you watch
people grass grow you know I didn't
really watch him grow but now that I
know his story and stuff like that I was
he's like he's been doing the UFC and
stuff like that I think back at things
I actually remember like when this is
like I was a fear factor another thing
that I think back a thing what that was
you that was you that was actually you
[ __ ] you know that's crazy watching
people's journeys like people get so
invested in someone else's Crofton
someone else talent that you want them
to succeed yeah what you want them to
succeed yes you want the best for them
and it's not enough crazy this mind you
actually want the best for them someone
should never met yeah I found a long
story short or like the the what's the
word I'm looking for the [ __ ] was the
word I'm looking for
more of the story the mark the way they
coat some hands murderous story is guys
[ __ ] support us man yeah if if you
think we're funny now or you think we're
good now
give us ten years man like said it takes
it takes a long time to own and
developed and you know make sure your
craft is elite enough to scratch and
we're just getting tired man and we
already got a good you know good fan
base and good good audience at the
moment but we want a great an amazing
audience but you guys are amazing at the
moment so you know just thank you just
[ __ ] thank you man that's Thao's the
motor story I want to thank you thank
you thank you so much guys that's nice
man
I liked that thank you yeah man you ever
not in your buns however not in Mahwah
have you ever knighted in your pants
actually in a like in your pants are so
left-field I know you don't strike me as
someone who has I don't think I have I
don't know about piss myself and purpose
that tell me I'm not in your pants do
you hang on
would you mean you pissed
on purpose business on purpose who what
why and where from so I was in thought
park with my family oh I was having for
parking like this and I'm press cover I
was in an amusement park anyway and I
was a kid and I think I was waiting for
my family or whoever I was with was on
the right and I was waiting for them to
come off so we can go to the next one
and I don't think I wanted to go into
our cart my bar was alone I remember
being alone but I had I had just come
off a water right so obviously I'm
soaked and I couldn't find a toilet so
for [ __ ] let me just piss myself
I remember word-for-word I have to
finish pissing myself I looked around
and made sure no was looking or see see
if anyone's looking at that oh [ __ ] all
the water rides I'm so wet remember
saying that is so random that's disgust
what was not as disgusting as [ __ ]
nice it sure is true is true but they're
not the same thing I was it was like it
was in those you know Meenu young in the
dry hump in days yes you use a dry hump
foot yeah obviously we would go and buy
herself a dry hump yeah yeah that's high
one time me and one ting would came in I
thought we were having sex in like my
body thought we were happy
yeah yeah found that The Strokes got
faster the like the friction got harder
harder was warm
oh we were she was panting lo and behold
I was like what 16 mmm 15 16 fam geez
geez geez but cool a know I heard that
waited ages just I couldn't let her know
what happened so I was just there just
didn't miss my body tingle - I um from a
dry hump I was like that's embarrassing
in my head I remember thinking that's
him Barisan and literally just nut in my
jeans like that's embarrassing oh my god
no I've got a story
I've got a story oh so this was back
when I used to live in Crystal Palace
this is when I was a kid me and my
sister used to share
room but we had separate beds obviously
so but it wasn't a bunk bed it was one
bed here one bed here and obviously back
when your kid you were horny little
[ __ ] I think I was it must have been
in primary school or maybe a seventh
we're down I was young what happened
primary school year seven I remember I
lived in Dagenham when I moved to like
when I was near a and yeah so I know I
was young young young and remember those
boxes like there weren't these boxes
that you have now there were the loose
like square boxes they're [ __ ] with
the with a button in the middle like the
flea one the short tinged with a button
in it and they used to ride up to
everyone's so obviously is the space
asleeping but I never use the weapons I
hate pyjamas
so he's always sleeping boxes or shorts
so one night of sleeping in boxes I was
Brosky or so horny I don't know why it
was just hormones of a year seven guy or
thirty I don't know it all was that I
was so horny and for some and I think I
was imagining stuff because I think I
was watching porn back then anyway
probably like that one sky like mine
yeah reporting so I must I must have
just finished watching it and then come
upstairs tomorrow my sister was in beds
and I wasn't obviously in my bed and I
was imagining imagining I was getting
[ __ ] bras and then somehow someway my
piece went through that hole in the
boxes and I just kept on mute so like
like you said you were dry hopping at
take I was basically dry humping my bed
wait felt so real James
that was my first that was my first
experience I felt so real I felt so real
I was going and going and I [ __ ]
night just hold the mattress on the
mattress I remember it was a silent one
oh my god right that was over half half
my life ago oh Jesus Christ that's funny
[ __ ] bro that was my imagination used to
I would have given anything literally
when I was a teenager yeah if someone
had said put your hand on the table I'm
gonna cut off the first knuckle or your
finger and
you can just have [ __ ] every night you
can just a [ __ ] like a girl just gonna
pay you were your [ __ ] and you go back
to sleep from when I was a teenager from
like 12 until what 15 16 I would have
happily done it I would giving up my my
pinkie see I was a that is unbearable
like is unlivable to be that horny when
you're a kid it's not funny it's not
funny it's really not funny it's not
funny it's like one of them ones is f
that's one of the times in your life
where you realize like Brock human
beings are just [ __ ] animals
oh yeah you just like you sit there I'm
an animal like that's extreme stuff I
literally go control myself what the
[ __ ] is going on I can't wait I can't
wait to like hat like for like my son to
grow up and we be in that yeah yeah and
he's just horny we're and he's just
upstairs fapping away everyday I it's
gonna make me laugh cuz you know what
it's like wow what even is this oh my
days
[ __ ] you know did you think your did did
you the first time you bust a nut do you
remember the very very very first I
don't think I ever wore
I don't know if that time I was talking
about in the bed was my first time oh I
remember that happened and I know it was
early in my life by don't if that wasn't
the first time or not I don't remember
the first time my boss'll up bro
yes I thought I broke it I thought I
broke it cuz I bashed because I would
before then I was bashing but nothing
would happen
yeah at the end I'll just bash until I'm
bored a bashing okay cuz I remember you
saying like you you didn't know like the
what so you just wanking it was like a
and then I'll be horny yeah and it would
help a little bit yeah but it wouldn't
get there was I would just be horny all
the time we're using imagination it was
important I think I was using my
imagination maybe a bit of both I can't
remember
no definitely imagination I definitely
knew what busting was when I was
watching porn okay that was a means to
an end
yeah okay so I would just be bash
bashing for nothing
yeah I know one day that's when like the
peak starts going up and you're like
we're moving somewhere and then from
when boss but like
nothing came out okay the first first
first time nothing came out my buddy
didn't know what was going on yeah but I
still got the tinkle tinkle young I was
young I was I was like if nothing came
out you must be young I must've been
like 11
but maybe 12 I don't know yeah must be
my eleven twelve and bro nothing came
out and but my piece was throbbing you
know I mean it was Robby had sex four
times in a row bro and yeah like a heart
and I was standing there a snake you're
just staring at na na I broke you pretty
broke it and even that I didn't even
know that [ __ ] was supposed to come out
of it anyway yes I was like [ __ ] it
broke but like how this is what I don't
remember that I don't remember the
transition from that fear yeah I think
it all my [ __ ] god I broke it yeah
love what the [ __ ] to get me set myself
to that point casually just how busting
nuts yeah like I don't remember the
transition yeah in my head I would have
thought that I would have been terrified
never do that though they're terrified
in my head I would have a lot right as
soon as you're moving up somewhere next
time stop my kids I don't care how good
it feels
stop its boy we're about to break it so
I don't know what happened boy I mean I
remember being terrified off I got funny
[ __ ] terrified but boy well I so all
we talk about is being horny teenagers
throw more time than none yes mum more
time than none yes because I feel like
it's very relatable
everyone if whether being a guy or go
you're gonna know what we're talking
about because the females are the
[ __ ] recipients of our horniness bro
they are if it was a horny than guys
anywhere I said that's what I keep
hearing but I don't think they truly
understand I I think adult females are
more horny than adult guys yeah but I
don't think anyone's more horny than
teenage guy I don't think that's humanly
possible because if that was like if
girls were morning
that he will be [ __ ] in the classroom
I couldn't sit still back in school
where you'd randomly get a boner in
class so remember and you'd have to
stand up and walk somewhere like listen
yeah stand up and read the passage in
the book or something you like but why
go boner bro it was so stressful in the
school trousers firm tight like so
stressful oh my days having a boner in a
public place is so embarrassing
it's so embarrassing and it's only so
much you can do there's nothing you can
just gotta sit there and wait there's
nothing you can do and like the more you
focus on it the bigger it gets and the
more you try and push it down the more
friction mean you can't touch it the
bigger we get that's where it wants its
Robin this is the throb bro you can't
touch me because that's exactly why once
my nervous oh yeah just leave it you
have to [ __ ] leave it to do a steak
and just just piss off in his own regard
I'll hate those times oh my days
[ __ ] safe I was funny do you remember
the era of when every guy used to get
the air pissed myself included yeah yeah
I remember that was a that was a serious
time bromas dem Amar'e and b2k times
everyone was getting their ears pierced
bro I remember in year 12 / little bit
ya 12/13 I was I went to boarding school
back then and everyone was most of my
friends like that's what at that point
had had their ears pierced mm-hmm
[ __ ] jealous hmm I want my ears
pierced but I'm shook of what my parents
again
you know I mean as an African as an
African person with an African family
and stuff like my parents don't even
want that I mean I wasn't even about to
try and do that and then [ __ ] pierce
my ears and stuff so I've got one of
those magnet ones you know the ones you
put the fing bags for the magnet there
yeah yeah they're not bangin but
obviously you've never worn on a magnet
because you've got you had your ears
pierced it would [ __ ]
King her for oh it would but Annie would
swell firm the pain just to feel amongst
the crew it would barking at my [ __ ]
element swell up so back in the hell so
much bro that sometimes because
obviously some magnet sometimes if you
like kids it's by accident it falls off
but you don't really feel it fall off
but because the magnet is summoned
density ill of the magnet will stay
there but the actual earring per se
would fall off and you won't even notice
and I'm sometimes I do that just like we
adjust it make sure it's know that I
know I'm either just embarrassing it's
[ __ ] embarrassing
yeah man is this everyone
I got the thing is I still I know you
mean cuz I got my ear pierced probably
late yourself everyone because my mom
was like [ __ ] oh yeah [ __ ] no you're
not getting his piss and I was that mum
let me just [ __ ] let me like I want
to yeah all my boys have but she's that
no no no no no in highs I don't know why
she said no because when you thinking
about it like why not why not yeah it's
not really gonna do anything
it doesn't mean yeah and it will and
even if it doesn't close up it's a tiny
little dot on you it I who kids and fast
at you but yeah I was desperate to get
me his piss and then I think I must have
been like what 15 mmm but I got my ears
pierced and I just for [ __ ] it and
there's one dad's what it did it just uh
[ __ ] this man I'm not doing it
but obviously just like you say then
beats UK times I wanted the fat guy man
singing yeah how are the fat joules you
first get funny bro and the big shiny
thing yeah but when you first get
appears yesterday the little training
studs little sparkle of waste my I look
like a princess I look like a little
princess who just got her is pissed
I felt so no and you have to wear for
like six weeks or before you can change
this if we can change it if the whole
new set just Oh bro it was six weeks of
her so by the time there's six weeks are
over I didn't even yeah yeah yeah it was
a [ __ ] joke that's fun hated it or
princess you know little princess that's
what I'd like
and when I was older I wanted I think
there's a round time I met you I wanted
the stretches Oh
really not big stress oh yeah yeah he
had those yeah yeah I was going to do it
and I think I bought some I'm fairly
certain I bought some no I did I did buy
some okay there are little spikes yeah
so you put the spikes in and then you
slowly gradually get deeper and deeper
firm I put into the tiniest bit fell how
much that hurt I was I'm on them I'm not
doing it that's what that's what enemas
feel like that's exactly what they
almost feel like
with a dick there's no how arrows edge
yeah it's just far from the start is
this a love is a rock and a hard place
may is its long
oh [ __ ] you I don't know how they found
that you women are the true MVPs boy
they are - we were talking about
yesterday just just what women go
through intersex yeah just just the
whole like spitting in a girl's mouth
[ __ ] just get rekt yeah yeah that's
right heads getting yanked you get
another life choked out are you nipples
getting twisted it's just long like it's
afterwards afterwards when the scars of
all running your throats been bruised
like mascaras running
you've got nut all over your face all
over your tits and you're just they're
just like what is what was that what is
this because I'm I escaped and then I'm
sorry the guys are clean clean she's
just their buns lemon she just bruised
them bad like what what is this why I
need to go through so fuss or not this
man just annihilated mean he's gonna
sleep I couldn't live through that yeah
but we will never know what it feels
like it's true you know I mean they love
it's my face but wait
well after Jesus once I bust my knot I
don't want anything to do with you
sometimes you know I mean because I'm
not there anymore like
no I'm back to my senses I mean back to
my sense the guy you met five minutes
ago isn't the same name like I'm just
done that's funny
my pokes that doesn't me [ __ ] far I
was gonna say oh that was so funny but
oh Jesus what did you even say I can't
remember
[ __ ] what was it gonna say I don't know
firm oh that's some one where are you
gonna [ __ ] I don't know man not even
know we're talking but yeah they love it
they clearly [ __ ] love it
that's so funny but oh yeah do say it
wasn't the guy was five minutes ago I'm
a different I'm a little bit different
guys I'm work James out like I'm give me
a laptop let me work I'm not this hungry
animal you met min ago what's the bus
Manali fam I don't want to be touching
on what I found I don't to be spoken to
I either want to sleep I just want to go
on my dad it's so weird
oh my doesn't make any sense there's
some there's a chemical imbalance I need
to know what the chemical process is
because once you get from people bro to
different people Jekyll and Hyde
literally Jekyll and Hyde usually and
you know when this is the thing this
this is this is what this is how do I
explain it
this is like the cover-up story that I'm
gonna break wide open yeah guys will say
anything
yeah to get [ __ ] oh yeah and that's
like how do I explain it you know when
you say like like a girl will always say
like I like to go rounds
I want to go round after round after
round
you here for it yeah right like cosplay
babes I'll give you proof all around
that of course not
as soon as the first round is done I'm
done
get off me they always fall for it oh
yeah they've that they've been through
this before
previously I know they have they always
fall for I wanted a rounds after rounds
I'm going to sleep I'm going to sleeping
again I'm house in that order bro and
you know when you'll just swimming in it
and you're like I could go round you
could visit typical rounds I know I
can't when they're not even yet you're
like Midway mean way you're like frog
this is going all night this isn't
[ __ ] going this is going all night I
don't give a [ __ ]
this is the best thing ever as soon as
you bust that nut bro sleep all out the
window you're different you can pay
couldn't baby yeah you say I'll give you
200 pounds for me get no no I have no no
interest no interest you could say like
would you rather [ __ ] me again I'll
[ __ ] go to Russia I'm the same
difference right now cuz it just doesn't
make any [ __ ] sense it makes no sense
but um yeah man [ __ ] it I'm are they
also everywhere I cooked some some good
ones today nice nice laughs am I the
[ __ ] for saying good when my son came
out to me ah that's so cold bro that's
so cold
coinkidink cuz that's from communy oh
yeah that original that that's when the
Korean guy oh yeah the Spanish teacher
the King John King John he's rockin John
yeah yeah what's his name in the day I
[ __ ] have no idea is something I got
my bed in the agile in the classroom is
that what the first time he does it yeah
when he so he's he's a Spanish teacher
yeah the Korean guy came John he's a
Spanish teacher in community yeah and
then he gets sacked and he signs up as a
student and then when he's a student
he's taken one of the classes and then
one of the teachers are saying something
ha
is that way originated from Ezra's from
no [ __ ] way incident we were [ __ ]
talking about charges given in community
before yeah but yeah full circle and I'm
[ __ ] love - I'm gonna watch community
again it's on I know it's on I'm gonna
[ __ ] binge it yes I never watch
community guys please watch it's
hilarious I'm hilarious
right this might sound bad but I've
always been the class clown funny type
of dude you shut up my son who's 19
loves it and he's more like a friend
than a son he's a great kid the other
days cute the other day he came to me
and told me that he had to tell me and
his mum something super important now we
had our suspicions but he confirmed them
when he told us that he was indeed gay
neither I nor my wife have a problem
with that so when he told us I laughed I
laughed and yeah ah ha go like this skip
from who knows what [ __ ] show that is
he didn't take it as well as I expected
his fight crime before running off and
slamming the door oh my god I thought it
was hilarious what do you guys think oh
I feel like obviously what as he said
prior him and his missus had their
suspicions hmm and when he said it
obviously confirmed the suspicious like
he said he had no problem with it
but I think it was just more of an input
it's a guy thing to do but always take
the piss out of something but even that
it don't mean it you I just take the
piss out like I can't handle serious
situation I can't deal with them yeah
like I have to laugh in some in some
aspect whatever comment on it I can make
it fun I had to make it funny for me to
deal with what's going I know what you
mean row the other day when you was like
god forbid when yesterday when you your
boy yesterday yeah they've heard the
heart attack yeah fam
I had to zip my mouth shut because my
initial impact is to make some kind of
joke
because I can't process how serious this
[ __ ] is I can't make I physically can't
process it like you know I have to make
a joke yeah and I was just like don't
james just die as people crying just
stop but yeah that's probably what I
would do
does it make him the [ __ ] yes and no
I don't know like for me it's like I've
always said like if my son's gay mmm I'm
pissed if he jumped out to me
anyway you don't need to be coming out
to me if but do you not feel like it's
not he's not doing it for you he's doing
it for him true it is for him it is this
is the thing right so this is the way I
would see innocent okay perfect cool
you're right this is how I would see it
he said it's a fine line so he's doing
if he of course is for him mmm so he's
come out as gay that's for him but at
the same time what am I even trying to
[ __ ] say I have at the same time like
don't expect me because like you said he
doesn't give a [ __ ]
I'm upset pops he doesn't really give a
[ __ ] yeah so that's his way in my eyes
that if if it was me and I'm making
jokes about it that's my way of letting
you know that I'm cool I'm cool with it
yeah like that that's all good yeah yeah
so like I don't want to take it
seriously because the more serious I
take it I've never liked when
something's really good something is
nothing but positive no one questions it
yeah not one just say yeah you don't you
don't sit in a in a silence serious
situation when something is positive if
we're sitting in a silence say and so to
sit down I need to tell you something
it's you're already Tommy's not hundred
N+ okay it makes sense yeah so for
making jokes it means I'm hundreds and
positive about it there's that's fine
okay I see that aspect but yet I would
that for me that's my best way to
translate it across rather than saying
okay cool I'm like I'm happy you told me
it cetera cetera like be yourself and
all that stuff like to me that's me I
could be hiding something I could be
hugging something back I might not be
happy about it but for me to be like gay
right okay big when you actually gay
that's just making a joke I'm to make it
light and obviously the same thing he he
might not be able to purchase situations
and his son should know that but I don't
know I don't know it's at the same time
it would have taken us on a lot of
[ __ ] guts
yeah sighs [ __ ] parents down and say
it like he would have built up in his
head [ __ ]
ages ages yeah so he's longing for
scenarios
yes you would have gone over all the
million different scenarios in his head
he's finally built up site his parents
down he's probably [ __ ] himself and
then man obviously when people don't
take something as serious as you do it's
a bit yeah it's a bit of a dick I feel
like well he's the guy not the father
but the son should know his father's
character anyway that's what I'm saying
so I understand the severity of the
scenario from the boys perspective
obviously cuz to come out to anyone
obviously you're doing it for yourself
but you just want to do it just to that
away off your shoulder yeah something
that eats people up for years and
decades like like we said the other day
about Joe from taiga King Joe exalt a
query yeah he once he told he's dad he's
dad said don't come to my funeral and
you drove up that Ridge that's a joke
that's that's extreme so for someone to
come out to someone I get the severity
of it obvious I would never I can
empathize rather let me not see I get I
can empathize because I would never
understand because it's not something
I've done or something experienced so I
feel like just based on that I feel like
I understand the father standpoint in
being funny because if that's his
personality that's his character but for
me I think I would have probably
acknowledged the situation on a more of
like a platonic way at first you know
made a joke often yeah yeah making a
joke off the bat sometimes could ease
the tension but if you'd like said did
he say slam didn't quite and I feel like
that's that's hard that's a hard thing
for anyone sup so I open up about
whether you're male or female and I just
feel like it's it's just it's a tough
one the top road it's a tough one yeah
obviously I feel like I feel it's a
tough one I don't think really anyone's
the [ __ ] in this one because the same
time they're both to blame not to blame
but obviously the son should know why I
was like anyway he said we said like I'm
I'm I'm a class clown as it is so the
son should know ways about so he
shouldn't be surprised by something like
that and at the same time he
that should read the room you hate the
[ __ ] room if you read the energy in
the room and if you feel like that's up
if you like if that was appropriate you
someone I kind of cried so clearly that
was inappropriate you read the [ __ ]
room breath and be a man rapidly wrap
yeah ma'am cool